dear evan hansen today is going to be an
amazing day and here's why
[Music]
we are going to interview each other
about our new film dear evan hansen
and i'll go first what would you write
in a letter to your younger self try not
to worry so much
it's okay to not be okay
it will be fine
stop wearing so many pillows
[Laughter]
i just read a mandlas note and i agree
don't wear another polo on top of
another polo because that wasn't for a
while you did the doubles on top of each
other
did you pop the colors
oh called next question i would write in
a letter to myself i would say
be more promiscuous oh
i feel i just want to say i feel very
official with this card
you sound a fish you're like yes ben
let's move on i'm just going to bring
this to your next interview
[Laughter]
sorry i have to rest it like this okay
sorry um if you met someone who knew
nothing about dear evan hansen
what would you tell them going into this
film
be prepared to cry
i hope that those who are feeling
isolated in their experiences will
partake in the viewing of this
i would say it's really good so you
should watch it
wow
i maybe would say nothing because i like
when people go in with no expectations
but if i had to say something i would
say
that it's unlike any movie musical
you've ever seen before i would say
prepare to cry
and also um
prepare to feel seen
really good
you're living your best kelly clarkson
life uh-huh yep right okay yes ben
how is preparing for a movie musical
different than preparing for a regular
movie that is not a musical i mean we
did a lot of time in the booth
a lot of time pre-recording
a lot of time rehearsing
many teas with cough drops stirred in
for me
personally so yeah that was really
different i feel like for you guys you
also had the choreo on top of that yes
that actually was exclusively the
rehearsal it was like how can we make
you
a dancer in three weeks
it worked
you are a dancer thanks kelly
[Laughter]
it's different because we get a
rehearsal process in at all beforehand i
feel like a lot of movies i've done
there's no you kind of show up and start
so it was just nice to like get our
bearings a little bit in that way and
also there was just the stress that you
have when you do a musical of like
preserving your throat and your voice
that doesn't usually come with a film so
it's just a little bit of an added
responsibility yeah i'd say a lot of
rehearsals lots of rehearsals lots of
singing lots of live singing that i've
never done on camera before
and also
tapping into a role that's been
played by so many
amazing people before you and wanting to
live up to that learning how to sing and
dance alongside tony people in days
okay what is your
go-to song to listen to when getting
ready for a scene what depends on the
scene but i do have an entire playlist
called weepy
each song
specifically can trigger a little bit of
teary teary for me so and they're mostly
music theater songs leslie odom jr is
my favorite
things god
piano soul in the middle of that just
cracks me open
um
yeah and then some fun stuff too you
know no one i used to always do um ain't
no body yes
that really gets me grooving really
but for what kinds of scenes
the the sad sad ones
no no
like today's an easy day today's like a
bunch of inserts
let's oh that's a great one yeah that
will get you pumped up yeah ready to
rock mine like serious one that i
listened to a lot during this shoot was
the song the sufian stephen song chicago
but covered by this group called the
staves which is these women who sing
like beautiful acapella harmony
and i can't listen to it
without crying right
because now it's just it's just
exactly it's literally right
um
it changes between different uh movies
but for this movie i listened to
um phoebe bridger's
latest album punisher a lot
specifically the song i know the end
it's beautiful and i guess a happier
song to get me in a happier place
and like pumped up would be
i know a place by muna
that was a good one i was listening to
that a lot on this movie i love you muna
are you watching i love you
i prefer to listen to the voices in my
head
nice valid i like that and a peaceful
piano playlist on spotify
oh that's nice
um
i
have a playlist called the bad place
wow
that i tap into sometimes depending on
the context uh and it's mostly like
weird ambient slash
spooky scary
weird stuff i was talking to an actor
once you told me like oftentimes
when we're like going to an emotional
place like what can trigger the motion
inside of us is like joy as opposed to
like pain or sorrow not really stuck
with me and so sometimes when
i'm like doing a scene that feels
emotional or i'm i it's more like
tapping into the nostalgia of the past
and so i'll listen to like a really
happy song from my childhood like
me my mom used to listen ain't no
mountain high enough all the time and
stuff and so like sometimes that's what
i'll go to depending on what what's
going on what's something new that long
time fans of dear evan hansen will
discover in this film something new that
fans will discover are two new songs um
that have been written for the film um
that i think fans will really love that
fit really beautifully into the score
and i think they'll also discover a
really nice new texture to the
relationship between ilana and evan that
doesn't exist on stage that i think
people are going to love
i think the cool thing about making this
musical into a movie is that we're
really getting the chance to see these
characters
physically up close so i think that
what's so cool about
seeing dear evan hansen
portrayed on film is
the fact that we're literally seeing how
these characters are feeling internally
which is very cool i think maybe they'll
be surprised by um kind of like the
integration of the music into the
narrative
because i i definitely was surprised by
it when we were filming it i was kind of
like how is this gonna turn out but um
it's great it's like very natural and
subtle and
and
yeah just like not integrated in a way
that that feels really unique i feel
like for me one is this cast is bonkers
so
that's
mostly new and
the thing for me that i'm looking
forward to most after seeing it like 400
times before on stage the opening up of
some things like requiem when you are on
the when you're walking through the
halls you're walking and the parallels
of the grocery store and the office and
like that like really did me in and then
same with the for forever actually
seeing that stuff like yeah i think the
opening up of the world that you thought
you knew but you get like
those deeper
3d glances into like what how much
further this story kind of is rooted
down into that was really cool what was
the most important thing to get right in
adapting from stage to screen i think
for me it was um
all the specificities in the in the
songs that i had to sing and also i
think just tackling
zoe's
resilience and trying to trying to
balance out her anger and her pain and
her sadness
while still keeping everything
grounded and still keeping keeping the
love for her family and for her brother
at bay i think that was the most
important thing for me i feel like
the stage version really
hits both like the heart and the
funny really well and i think like
making sure that translates and so
that's not just like a very sad story it
was definitely your job
it's a lot of pressure
you are the comedic relief
i think
what felt challenging to me and i really
wanted to get right was kind of like
getting into the psyche of like an
overachieving kid
and i was really nervous about it
because i feel like uh the alana that
you get to see on stage
is like very in control and and very
assertive and
you know you can and everyone kind of
find it kind of follows her as a leader
and i really wanted to incorporate those
elements into her but
also like explore
the machinations of her
and why she might be feeling alone and
why she might connect to evan and that
was also already folded into the script
because of what levinson wrote and so it
was just kind of like leaning into the
beauty of his writing and everything but
i think the solana is a bit different
and it makes me
a little nervous sometimes but but i
think um
i don't know it felt it felt important
to me to kind of like
uh lean into
almost how isolating it can be to be um
a kid who like
who's whose main priorities to do well
um i feel like those kids are often not
like actually the cool kids or the ones
who are in control that have a lot going
on and so yeah making sure we're
incorporating that and especially
incorporating that into the writing of a
song in a way that felt like real and
truthful felt a little nerve-wracking
but was also really gratifying
i definitely wanted to get
the feeling right i mean just generic as
that sounds like
if you were there or when anyone has
experienced the stage show like it's
such a visceral thing that you see
people go through
and it turns out to be quite a necessary
thing you see when you walk out the door
where people either come back or you can
just see them
even standing there just kind of i don't
like in a state of shock because they're
just they're moving through something
and so for me i wanted to get the vibe
right honestly i wanted to be like
this is a different moment we're in
and i think in some ways it's even more
timely now so i just thought like we
have a real opportunity here and
yeah i hope that translates yeah i agree
with what everyone has said i would say
from my personal standpoint i really
wanted to
make sure that the audience understood
what's happening in evan's mind at all
times because i think he's doing a lot
of
morally ambiguous things and in the
musical i get to turn out to the
audience and like feel whether i am
connected to them or if that it just is
very tangible whether that's
them going on board with the journey is
happening or not whereas we're sort of
having to preempt that in the film so i
think throughout i just wanted to keep
in mind that i was communicating
properly in his emotional state and why
he's doing the things that he's doing
and why he carries on at every step of
the way when he could kind of stop why
does he keep going
um i think that was important to get
right
[Music]
i could do who i am
just how broken i
am i already know you
and i love you
i have to tell them
[Applause]
[Music]
you